>> Jeremy Bailenson: Thank you for hosting
and it's an absolute pleasure to be here.
I've lived in Mountain View for about eight
years now and have been walking my dogs in
this neighborhood for quite some time.
Obviously you're at the center of the technology
universe and I'm just excited to be here and
to share my work with you.
And so, I'm a professor and I'm part social
scientist and part engineer.
For the last 15 years I have been studying
the psychology of avatars, meaning I build
virtual environments.
I put people in these representations I call
avatars and I study the psychological effects
of spending time inside an avatar.
I've been doing this work for a long time
and it's real exciting for me that the work
you guys are doing the work that others are
doing in Silicon Valley that has made the
work that I do from this weird science fiction
stuff, -- think about a guy until the late
90s who is studying avatars to really a household
name.
It's especially fun for me to talk about this
work that I've been doing for so long to you
guys.
Everything I'm going to talk about today -- I'm
going to give you a very broad sense of what
I'm doing.
All the work I'm talking about is published.
This is the URL of my lab.
You can go on the lab's website and see all
the PDFs of the published work.
I'm going to give you a really broad perspective.
I'm going to cover 50 experiments today in
35 minutes time.
I'm not going to bore you with details about
the control condition,s about the measures
that we used.
Feel free to ask that in the question and
answer session.
I've also been asked to tell you to hold your
questions until I stop speaking at about 12:45.
At that point we'll do a formal question and
answer using the microphone.
Okay.
So the big question we're going to ask today
is when I am in an avatar in virtual space,
there's certain rules in the physical world
that govern all social interaction.
When you enter a virtual world, all of those
rules are thrown out the window.
When you interact with a virtual version of
someone, say you're in hangout in Google plus
or you're Skypeing or in a place called Second
Life as a virtual world or a video game, you're
interacting with virtual representations of
other people.
And the rules that govern face to face, --my
identity, how attractive I am, how tall I
am, my gender, even my species--, all of these
rules can be thrown out the window.
What I'm going to do today is describe to
you a world where social interaction is changed
in a way that we've never really seen before
as a human specie.
My book is called Infinite Reality and it's
written with Meredith's father, Jim Blascovich,
who has been a great mentor to me, and this
book really covers the history of our work,
the 15 years of our work.
We write it as scientists but we also write
it as journalists.
I have the luxury of being in Silicon Valley,
getting to go to Jaron Lanier's attic and
look through his materials.
I really interviewed the main players in the
history of this.
I really think you should view this book as--.
If you're curious about what avatars are,
or what virtual worlds, virtual reality is,
and want to understand the psychology behind
it, the social science behind it, and how
it's really going to change the world, that's
what this book does.
So please, if you enjoy this talk do read
the book.
How many of you, show of hands, have worn
a helmet and walked around in a virtual reality
before?
About 20 percent of you, great.
So I'm going to show you a video of a gentleman
in my lab and what is he doing?
>>Male #1: A tight rope?
>> Jeremy: A tight rope is close.
We're forcing him to walk the virtual plank.
So what he's seeing when he looks down is
the Wile E. Coyote-type chasm with a rickety
plank.
And how does virtual reality work?
The way virtual reality works is by tracking
and rendering.
So we've got sensors in the room that are
tracking the way that his head moves, where
his legs are, where his body position is,
where his head is turned.
,Physical cameras in the room track those
positions.
About 100 times a second, a computer senses
his movement and redraws the virtual world
to reflect that movement.
So if he walks one meter in the physical world,
the virtual world is drawn one meter behind
him so that every action is accompanied by
a virtual reaction.
That's all sent to some audio-visual display.
In this case, he's wearing what we call the
HMD, the headed mounted display, and the cycle
of tracking and rendering happens about a
hundred times a second.
So he walks, the world is updated and it feels
very realistic as you're walking around.
As you watch to this guy, you can see he's
feeling very high what we call 'presence',
meaning he forgets that he's in the physical
room as he's walking this virtual plank.
To give you a sense, I've probably run over
5,000 people over this virtual plank in the
last 15 years through demonstrations, through
experiments.
On average, when you look at adults, that
is people my age 20s, 30s, 40s, 50s, one in
three people won't step within a meter of
the edge of that pit.
They'll see that plank and they just won't
go there.
It's really compelling.
You're all welcome to come to my lab and do
this experience.
Stanford has rebuilt my lab.
It's really cutting edge and we do tours once
a week on Fridays for the informed public.
What makes, I think, this book very relevant
and timely and also relevant to the Google
audience, is that it's no longer, VR is no
longer for people with expensive labs at big
Universities.
So Jaron Lanier, who is the pioneer in many
ways of the field, who coined the term 'virtual
reality', has said for decades, as long as
you've got to wear crap on your head and have
a dedicated room to run this thing, virtual
reality is never going to be important.
But what is virtual reality?
We just talked about VR as tracking your motions
and then
rendering the world, drawing the world, and
showing it to you.
And tracking your motions, a great team from
Tel Aviv, a company called tracking your motions
PrimeSense , using infrared cameras has not
solved this problem but all of a sudden made
tracking--.
By leaps and bounds, we can now track very
easily.
So how many of you guys have used the Microsoft
Kinect?
Okay, only three or four of you.
This is, if you have children or grandchildren,
this is--.
They're all going to be clamoring for that
this Christmas.
Many kids have this in their homes already.
This uses a single camera to track all of
your body motions.
The hardest part about virtual reality, knowing
what your body is doing physically that used
to require a room with zillions of cameras,
is now in every living room in the country
, or half the living rooms in the country
right now.
The Kinect is actually the fastest selling
consumer electronic product ever.
Everybody has this half of VR.
The other half of VR is something we're calling
autostereo.
This is something called a lenticular display
which gives you stereoscopic vision without
you even having to wear glasses such as when
you go to the theater.
How many of you have used the Nintendo 3DS?
Okay.
Nintendo 3DS has--, beams of hologram half
way between you and the game that you're holding.
It uses technology called lenticular displays
that refracts light in various directions.
It's very similar, you know those postcards
that you use, those cheap post cards that
give you a sense of stereo.
Had it for decades.
It's a very expensive version of that.
Everything I'm going to talk about has been
done in a fancy lab.
But this year, in particular, VR, tracking
your movements, and showing you a immersive
perceptual experience, is in the living room.
So everything that we study as a lab and that
we talk about in this book is now being done
on the school buses, in the classrooms, and
in your homes.
But I'm a social scientist and I'm not a technologist
as my primary field and what I study is social
interactions.
So when you're a subject in my lab we take
two photographs of you.
We then have a group of undergraduates in
a room networked down the hallway and they
feverishly drag these points onto your face
in something called photogrammetric software
and after I get a front on and a side shot
of you 25 minutes later when you enter virtual
reality you're wearing a 3D model of your
own head.
So what does this look like?
This is my colleague Jack Loomis.
Those are two photographs of him.
And this is a 3D model of his head and face.
It's a digital model.
It can be animated so any set animation I
can fathom we can make his head do.
It lasts forever the same way anything digital
does.
I can make a million copies at a whim.
A little digression.
How many of you guys have seen the commercial
with virtual Orville Redenbacher?
When you get done with this, go to Youtube
and type in virtual Orville Redenbacher and
you'll see that Orville Redenbacher passed
away some years ago.
His grandson gave permission to an advertising
agency to use the hundreds and hundreds of
minutes of video that they had from these
television commercials.
Hours and hours of video.
They reconstructed a 3D model of him from
beyond the grave.
Orville now acts in commercials without having
given permission to do so because once you
built a virtual representation, it can do
anything an animator can dream of.
So Orville from beyond the grave is dancing
around with an iPod and saying this iPod is
light and fluffy just like my popcorn.
It holds 30 gigs.
It really raises questions.
When I build your avatar, it lasts for longer
than you do and I have complete control over
its actions.
So one of the themes of this talk today is
in a world where I've built a version of you,
what is that world like and what happens when
I've got a version of you that can do things
that you don't necessarily do.
And it's really fascinating space as a social
scientist, as a technologist.
But it's not enough to make an avatar look
like you.
The avatar also has to behave like you.
And what I'm going to show you here is software
that we use,without putting anything on your
face, tracks your facial expressions.
So this is the model that I built in the previous
slide.
This is the real-time video that we get from
a crappy $30 webcam and this is me animating
that model based on a computer vision algorithm
that tracks 22 points on your face.
We're deforming this model based on knowing
what the face is doing.
So you walk into my lab.
We build this model of you from those photographs.
30 minutes latter when you enter virtual reality
you are being seen by others not only with
a model that looks like you but literally
expresses every facial expression that you're
doing and captures all the nuances of your
emotions.
And it's a really powerful experience.
I want to bolster the point about who is using
avatars?
Because again, it used to be an academic question
and it's no longer an academic question.
And what I really want to point you toward
is this stat on the bottom.
So a colleague, my colleague Don Roberts from
Stanford studies children with media use.
He did a study with Kaiser Family Foundation
that was published last year.
He presented this to Congress.
And he surveyed kids' media use.
So kids between the ages of 8 and 18 are spending,
on average, outside the classroom almost eight
hours a day consuming digital media.
Of those 8 hours a day 1.25 hours on average
are spent using avatars and video games.
To put in in perspective, the amount of time
they spend looking at print is 38 minutes
a day, okay?
So they're spending over three times as much
time in an avatar as they're reading newspapers,
books, everything combined.
So the idea of, the question of what do avatars
do to society is no longer one that we need
to think about in terms of the future.
Our kids are living, breathing, and eating
digital media all day and a lot of these are
spent wearing these avatars which can be very
different from them.
Why is this important?
Sometime ago we developed this theory of transformed
social interaction which is not a new idea.
A lot of these ideas have been taken from
science fiction novels.
It's as old as humans, this idea of behaving.
But in the physical world right now what I
do you guys see.
So, if I make a social blunder, I make a bad
facial expression, I curse by accident, I
trip and fall, what I do you guys see.
When we're interacting via avatars -- let's
revisit how virtual reality works -- The way
that it works is, I take a step a meter forward.
In my system, it tracks my motion.
My computer automatically sends you that I've
moved.
And then on your computer you've got a version
of my digital model, you draw me in a different
location.
So the idea is I perform on my end.
My computer sends you high level information
about the nature of that behavior.
You draw it locally on your end.
And that happens hundreds of times a second
and it happens with you guys, too.
So if one of you guys yawn, your computer
senses your mouth opened, sends that to my
computer and I draw you yawning.
That's fundamentally different from a video
conference because in a video conference all
you're doing is sending pixels over the network.
So whatever I'm doing, you capture that image
and that image is automatically sent in a
non-smart way over the network.
Is that difference clear?
Why is that important because it allows transformed
social interaction.
Instead of seeing the actual Jeremy, you will
see an optimized, strategically-transformed
version of me that has been chosen specifically
to accomplish some conversational goal.
So everyone in this room can be seeing a different
version of me one that I've chosen because
it's going to help me sell you guys books,
okay?
And that sounds very abstract now.
I'm going to now take it through lots and
lots of empirical examples that should convince
you quite robustly that this is something
we need to think about.
So first one I want to talk about me transforming
my avatar to influence other people.
And the first study that Jim Blascovich and
I did in the late 90s deals with what we call
augmented gaze.
As humans we've known for a long time eye
contact is important.
As psychologists for the last hundred years,
about, we've run experiments looking at this.
And other than me poking you in the chest
physically me, looking you in the eye is the
most important nonverbal tool I have.
It makes your heart beat faster.
It makes you listen more to what I say.
It makes you remember what I say.
It makes you more likely to look back at me
and to speak to me.
We know from tons of research that eye gaze
is important.
But in a physical room, I have a problem.
So right now there's about 65 of you in this
room and I can only look at each of you in
the eye for less than three percent of the
time, two percent of the time.
I can look at you all in the eye but only
one at a time.
In the virtual world, it's free for me to
send all of you varying information about
where my eyes are pointing.
It could be the case as I'm giving this talk
every single person in this audience can feel
as if I'm just looking at you and perceiving
that I'm giving the talk in that manner.
So to test this idea, we brought in three
people.
We put them all in virtual reality.
And this guy randomly get assigned to be the
teacher.
These two guys randomly get assigned to be
the learners.
Unbeknownst to the teacher who's looking trying
his best to look at both of them we've taken
his head movements and each one of these guys
sees the teacher looking at him for 100 percent
of the social interaction.
Okay?
Why did we do that?
The answer was, it's the late 90s.
I'm not a fantastic programmer and this was
the easiest thing we could think of.
I always like to say as a programmer of artificial
intelligence, we start with something really
simple and we examine the social effects.
So if an algorithm that was so dumb which
is simply make this guy stare at both people
for the entire time, if that works, then you
can imagine an algorithm that added a little
bit of noise or only looked at you if you
weren't talking to them or did it only for
50 percent of the time.
So what does this look like for learners?
Imagine I'm giving this talk and the entire
time I'm talking, everything I say, I'm looking
right at you for this whole time.
You can imagine this is a strange social interaction,
right.
So the way we run social experiments, we typically
bring in triads.
We bring in 100 triads and we examine their
behavior.
We've now replicated this study four separate
times, hundreds and hundreds of people.
And we get four things consistently.
The first thing that you get is people can't
stand this, okay?
[audience chuckles] They're extremely uncomfortable.
Humans rarely look at each other for more
than 7 seconds.
Ever, unbroken.
And that's typically if you're intimate with
someone.
These are people that for a 20 minute lecture
got stared at the entire time.
And people are not comfortable at all with
this.
However, not a single person has ever detected
that it's not real gaze.
So no one has said, "you know that guy stared
at me the whole time but I think it's computer
gaze not real gaze".
Not a single person has ever thought that.
You don't like it but you think it's real.
The third thing that we get is attention.
So if I'm a teacher, if I'm a salesman, if
I'm a politician, if I'm trying to get the
message to you, half the battle is getting
you to listen and with virtual reality one
point I want to return to toward the end of
the talk is whenever you're in a virtual simulation,
everything you do is tracked.
Meaning recorded.
Everywhere your eye points; where your body
is standing; every little behavior you can
ever imagine doing gets dumped to a file so
we can go through that file and actually look
at where you're looking.
When I give you guys 'super-gaze' as a group,
you guys return my gaze more often than when
I do my normal gaze.
So, just with a simple change to where my
head is pointed, all of you are getting different
versions of me.
It took me literally eleven lines of code
to do this, all right?
This is not hard to do.
You take the packet saying where the eye direction
is and you change it a little bit.
Not hard to do.
We're changing where you're looking, where
you're pointing your head.
But the fourth thing and the most important
thing is social influence.
So in this experiment, we designed a survey
that Stanford students had to sign when they
left which was very unpopular.
If you are caught on Stanford's campus without
your identification.
you are going to get in trouble.
So you can imagine nobody wants to sign this.
But the odds of you signing this are higher
if you get 'super-gaze' than if you get a
normal type gaze where you can look at people
one at a time.
So with eleven lines of code, I'm changing
the amount of time you're listening to me.
And then I'm also increasing the probability
that you're going to be influenced by what
I say in a persuasive manner.
Next line of studies is called digital chameleons.
This takes a powerful idea called of mimicry.
A woman named Tanya Chartrand in the late
90s, ran a very famous psychology experiment.
She had subjects go into interviews and the
subjects either mimicked the gestures of the
interviewers.
And so, if the interviewer crossed his legs,
then the subject crossed her legs.
If the interviewer, if she leans forward then
the subject, he would lean forward.
So we just told people face to face to go
in and mimic the gestures of the interviewers.
Nobody consciously recognized the mimicry,
but people who went in and mimicked the interviewer
were more likely to get the job than people
who didn't.
One of the overriding themes of social psychology
is people love themselves.
And if you can subtly manipulate that, you
are more effective.
We said wait a minute how does virtual reality
work?
VR works because I'm sending you information
about my behavior so you can draw me locally
on your machine doing it.
It is trivial.
It is literally four lines of code for me
to take that packed you sent me which is telling
you your behavior, hold on to it for a few
seconds, put my name on it and send it right
back to you.
So the technology is built for mimicry.
And so what does this look like.
This is Nick Yee.
He's a brilliant PhD student who's done much
of this research and all we're doing here
is that she's trying to persuade him about
this policy to have your ID card.
And what he's doing, he's moving and listening.
Her head movements are a four second mirror
of his.
Okay?
So he looks up.
One, two, three, four, she looks up.
Everything he does is a -- everything she
does is a slow mirror of him.
Why do we do it this way?
Again, we start off real simple on the artificial
intelligence.
Let's start easy.
Whatever he does, she's going to do four seconds
later.
At this rate, a four second lag with exact
mimicry, only one in 20 people consciously
recognize that the avatar was mimicking them.
So even though I'm stealing your exact head
movements, barely anyone has the ability to
explicitly realize this is happening.
And those instances tended to be if somebody
spun around in their chair, okay?
[laughter] Or something very extreme.
We didn't build for the exorcist.
So what happened?
The exact same things as in the previous studies.
Nobody detects this consciously, but when
I mimic you, when my avatar mimics you, you
look at me more and you're more likely to
sign this petition later on that you wouldn't
have signed otherwise.
You also rate me as more attractive, more
credible, more trustworthy, and you like me
more.
So really simple tweaks I can do to my avatar,
automatically, that are having drastic changes
on your nonverbal behavior, on what you say,
and ultimately how you decide to live certain
aspects of your life.
Which brings me to this next study which doesn't
look at facial mimicry but -- sorry doesn't
look at nonverbal mimicry but looks at your
face.
So I want to show you a video now and I want
you to be extremely impressed by this video.
The reason I want you to be impressed is because
this video e built in 2003 using $19 software
in less than 20 minutes by a freshman communication
major, okay?
It took no training.
And it was cheap and it took no time.
And you can see it is a morph from Arnold
Schwarzenegger to Gray Davis.
And all we're doing is blending one face to
another and it's really simple to do this.
And we wanted to ask the question, if my avatar
takes on your facial characteristics, is that
going to change how you interact with me?
So think about this Brady Bunch grid of faces
that we have on a hang out and one could do
with this.
What do I know about if your face looks like
mine from the social psychology literature?
If you look more like me, you're more willing
to buy something from me.
Studies by Dovidio have shown that if I'm
lying on the ground clutching my knee in agony,
the odds of you stopping to help me increase
if you look like me.
And Lisa DeBruine in England has demonstrated
that if your face looks more like mine, I'm
more likely to hand my children over to you
to babysit for them.
As humans, we like to think that we're this
very deep race where we look to the inner
beauty of people but it turns out subtle characteristics
of your face and body have drastic consequences
to how you interact with others.
I worked my colleague Shanto Iyengar who is
a political scientist and we wanted to look
at the 2004 presidential election.
Okay?
And what we did is we had three groups of
subjects.
One group of subject had pictures of George
Bush and John Kerry that were just like the
actual pictures of Bush and Kerry.
So this middle row here are the actual pictures
of Bush and Kerry.
We then got a focus group to collect from
about 600 people to passively acquire photographs
of voters from across the country.
And we got a national random sample.
Meaning it wasn't just college kids.
We paid money to get variance in socioeconomic
status, location, age, all these important
demographic variables.
Then over the next six months, we had undergraduates
morph the faces of the potential voters with
Bush and Kerry.
That is a picture of me before I got tenure.
[laughter] You can see I was much more clean
cut then.
This is a picture of George Bush and on the
top right is the 60/40 blend between me and
Bush.
We've now run this experiment five separate
times.
Over 1,000 people.
We've asked them to write a paragraph about
the picture of George Bush.
Write a paragraph about what his face looks
like.
To date, not a single person if you stable
them 40% on the blend, on the has ever consciously
detected that his own face has been put in
the candidate.
Nobody has any idea consciously that this
is occurring.
This is a woman in my lab, Julia.
This is her with John Kerry.
Three groups of subjects.
If you had the normal Bush versus Kerry meaning
just the actual photographs of them.
For a third of our subjects, his or her own
face was morphed with George Bush.
And for another third of our subjects, his
or her face was morphed with John Kerry.
And what we simply did is, a week before the
election, we asked which of them they were
going to vote for.
And what we demonstrated is that in the control
condition actual photos we exactly replicated
the national sample.
It was 46/44 in favor of Bush.
Bush wins by a landslide when the subject's
face was morphed with Bush by 20 points and
Kerry actually wins by 7 among the people
with whom Kerry's face was morphed.
So think about this.
A week before the election, who you say you're
going to vote for is based on whether or not
the candidate looks more like you.
So we got this data.
And as citizens we were terrified but as social
scientists we were very excited [laughter]
and we sent this to the best journal in political
science and they rejected it without even
sending it out for review.
They said the voter is not rational.
Sorry.
They said the voter is rational.
They don't make decisions based on this.
The whole field of political science is based
on that notion.
In order to publish this work, we actually
had to replicate it in five separate studies
over a period of five years with different
candidates., 2008 elections, Small elections.
This effect doesn't go away.
One of the most powerful effects we demonstrated
in the lab is if my face steals portions of
your face ,you're going to like me better
and choose me in ways of social influence.
And what does this mean for the world of Google,
the world of online social interaction?
It's trivial to grab someone's face and to
morph my face with it.
What we demonstrated is very important decisions
can be based on a simple blend of my face
with yours.
Next line of studies we did was, can I train
a teacher to be a better teacher with a simple
tracking algorithm?
So, in this room, I'm doing my best to spread
my eye gaze as best as I can but it's hard.
As I am talking, it's very hard to hit everyone
in the room and as we've demonstrated that
top graph there is a U shaped birds eye view
of a classroom where the teacher is is the
blue T. The white cubes are pupils.
This graph here is the percentage of time
people get ignored And what you see is that
you guys on the corner, you guys get ignored
for about one third of my lecture.
What if you gave a teacher a tool which simply
showed me when I am not looking at you.
And all we did is take the tracking data that
you naturally get from a virtual reality simulation
and if I'm not looking at you, you start to
disappear.
So you've actually start to turn transparent
and simply gave the teacher this tool as they
gave their lessons.
What you see there is this graph here where
not a single person in the room gets ignored,
ever.
And just using a simple tool of spreading
awareness of eye gaze, you're demonstrating
better learning in the classroom.
So again, really cheap easy ways using things
you can glean from the virtual world as a
way of increasing someone's performance.
I've taken this exact paradigm and I've worked
with Peter Mundy who's at UC Davis, who works
with autistic children that have a hard time
maintaining eye contact.
And what we've done is we've actually given
them training simulations to help remind them
to look people in the eye.
And we've run two pilot studies now with very
encouraging results.
So I think there's some great applications
of using VR towards helping people that have
issues with social interaction.
All right.
I've talked a lot and hopefully I've convinced
you that I can use VR, my avatar, to influence
you guys.
That there's things I can do that are going
to make you more likely to agree with me.
Well, what happens to me?
We now all understand that I can influence
you guys.
But when I am changing my avatar, what are
the implications to me?
How does that affect me?
And that's a separate line of studies I want
to talk about now.
So the paradigm here that we use here is a
stranger in the virtual mirror.
So a typical subject will walk in the room
and we're tracking his motions as he walks
around.
This is kind of an old virtual world but it's
good to get it used again.
This is Nick Yee.
He's walking around.
He walks up to a virtual mirror. and a typical
subject in our studies we'll have them spend
two minutes in front of the mirror gesturing
back and forth.
So here you can see he's moving his head back
and forth.
And he's a white man.
He now is going to bend down and lose his
mirror image for a second.
We track all of his movements.
He pops up.
And he's now a woman of color.
And the question we ask is, if I change your
identity in a virtual world, do you come to
embody the social category of your avatar
compared to the social category of yourself.
So can you use an avatar -- or does an avatar
change your identity?
Small point of diversion here.
Have you guys heard World of Warcraft?
It's a video game where you have avatars.
The average player of World of Warcraft is
in his late 20s.
How many hours a week do you think he plays?
>>Male #2: 40
>>Jeremy: 40 is on the high end.
On average it's close to 20.
There are many people who spend 40.
I'm saying on average the player is close
to 20.
So think about, I put somebody in this for
about 90 seconds.
A World of Warcraft player, he's spending
about 20 hours a week, in an avatar that could
be a different gender, it could be different
species.
There's all sort of things that could be transformed
about this.
So the idea of your virtual self being very
different from your physical self, is a common
one.
So in our typical experiments, you've got
the subject.
He walks up to the virtual mirror and sees
himself in the mirror as something.
And I'll talk about what that is in a second.
He turns around and there's another person
to see, we'll call the confederate.
He's part of the study and he has a set script
that he talks to the subject about.
So the idea is I'm the subject, I look in
the mirror, I see myself differently.
I turn around and then I talk to someone else
and I think that other person sees me with
a new feature.
And that sounds very abstract.
Let me talk you through one of them.
The first study that Nick wanted to do was
attractiveness.
We think as humans this enlightened species
but it turns out if you're good looking, you're
more extroverted.
There's lots of changes in your behavior.
Being good looking does change lots of psychological
attributes that people have.
But in the virtual world, beauty is free.
So everyone can be good looking.
So Nick wanted to ask if I make you attractive
or unattractive in the virtual world, how
does that change your behavior?
What he did is a study where subjects walk
to the mirror.
They saw themselves in an avatar that had
carefully been chosen to be either one standard
deviation more attractive than average or
one standard deviation less attractive than
average.
Keep in mind this is very subtle.
It's not as if -- not a single person has
any idea they've got the good looking one
or the bad-looking one.
All this is working on a subconscious level.
And it's all -- no one's told they're in a
good-looking or bad-looking avatar.
The confederate then says to the subject,
"come on, over here."
"come over here I want to talk to you."
And the first thing we measure is how close
the subject will stand to the confederate.
When you have a good looking avatar, you will
step a meter closer to the confederate than
when you have a bad looking avatar.
So a fundamental way about how you space yourself
in public spaces is changed by a very subtle
tweak to your avatar.
We then tape record everything that you say
in a 20 minute discussion with the confederate.
We take those tape recordings and we mail
them off to nonverbal judges who are trained
in actually seeing -- detecting how personable
you are by your voice.
When you have an attractive face, for only
two minutes in a mirror, you speak more personably,
you reveal more information about yourself.
So a tiny tweak to your avatar is changing
how you interact nonverbally and what you
say.
In the next study Nick ran, he looked at height.
So in the physical world, in the United States,
height is correlated with income.
It's also correlated with confidence in situations.
A very depressing study out of the University
of Chicago got back-end data to online dating.
And it turns out, for men, for every inch
you are under 5'10", in order to get the same
number of hits as a guy who's an inch taller,
you have to make an extra $30,000.
[laughter] . So you can actually put a price
to height in the world of online dating.
But again, in the virtual world, height is
free.
And so what Nick the did is he had the subject
either be ten centimeters taller, very subtle,
nobody notices this consciously.
Or ten centimeters shorter than the confederate.
He then had them do a money-splitting game
called the 'ultimatum game' which is a task
used by economists, a standard way of gauging
economic performance.
When I am ten centimeters shorter than you,
-- again I don't consciously notices this--
No one's actually perceiving the height difference
in an explicit way--.
When I am ten centimeters shorter than you,
I am three times as likely to lose the negotiation
than when I am the same height or taller than
you.
This also occurs independent of your physical
height.
So regardless of my physical height, it's
my virtual height which is changing my behavior.
So real economic ramifications of a tiny tweak
of your avatar's height.
All these studies, by the way, I know they
sound a little bit out there.
They're all published and just about every
one of them has been replicated more than
once.
Meaning, when we try to go publish it the
reviewers say, "are you sure?"
And they make us go back and do it again.
And yes, we're sure.
These are really powerful effects.
The big question everyone asks is, "okay,
that's fine, but I'm not spending my whole
life in avatars.
What happens when I leave?"
So with the attractiveness study, Nick ran
a study, a follow-up, where you were attractive
in the virtual world.
He then takes you out, pays you for the study,
walks you down the stairs and you're about
to leave the building.
Right as you're about to leave, another graduate
student runs up to you and says "wait, wait,
wait.
I've got to get ten more subjects for my dissertation.
If you fill out this questionnaire for five
minutes, I'll pay you $20."
Or $10.
Everybody does it.
No one has any idea it's related to this study.
The survey is an online dating form.
And part of it is choosing people you think
will go out with you.
So people with whom you think you have a shot.
Half an hour later, if I had a good looking
avatar, the confidence that you got from that
actually changes who I'm going to pick.
So this experience in the virtual world doesn't
stay there; it changes at least for half an
hour in this instance who I am outside.
With the height study, Nick did a very clever
manipulation where you're taller or shorter
than the avatar in the virtual world.
He took the helmets off of you and then you
met each other on chairs designed to ensure
that your height was exactly the same and
then repeated the negotiation and got the
exact, identical results.
So this hierarchy that was formed from a height
differential extends face to face and you
still lose the negotiation.
Very powerful in that sense.
I want to shift now and I want to talk about
a different phenomenon that deals with the
self and I call this Veja Du.
I feel like I've never been here before.
And this takes the idea of Orville Redenbacher.
What would happen if someone built that when
he was alive?
As a human species, avatars are giving us.
It's weird for this to happen actually.
In the history of media, avatars are giving
us something we've never, ever had before
as a perceptual experience.
To me, it's flabbergasting.
I think it should be exciting to you as well.
We've always had mirrors.
We've been able to see ourselves.
We've always been able to go up to water and
look at ourselves.
In the last 50 years, we've been able to look
at ourselves asynchronously.
Meaning, I can look at something I did on
video tape twenty years ago.
For the first time ever, as people, we have
the ability to see ourselves doing something
we've never physically done.
Somebody builds my avatar, any animator can
make it do anything he or she wants.
For the first time ever, I can look at a screen
and see something that looks just like me
doing something I've never [physically done.
I can't underestimate, as a social scientist,
how powerful this is or how -- just how strange
this is going to make the world.
We can talk about applications later.
The first study we wanted to do -- this is
Jesse Fox's dissertation deals with health
behaviors.
So Americans we know we're supposed to exercise
more.
We're supposed to be healthy, but that message
doesn't get through.
Jesse wanted to make it visceral.
And so, what she did is, she built--.
All you guys walk in the lab.
We built your faces.
And then you have to exercise in physical
space.
So here's the video of that.
Every three times that your knees cross your
chest the avatar which looks just like you.
It's got your exact face -- loses a pound.
So after 20 minutes, you watch your avatar
lose weight and get to what Jesse defined
as an ideal weight based on some health, government
standard.
For ten minutes you do that.
We then force him to stand still and all the
weight comes back.
So what we're doing in a very visceral way.
From here on out, what we can talk about is
VRs as a really cool tool to use avatars to
change behaviors that are difficult to change
and entrenched.
So 24 hours later if you got this simulation,
we asked you to keep a diary and then turn
in the diaries to us.
We -- you know that we're reading them.
There's nothing personal in there.
If you got this simulation, over the next
24 hours, you would exercise on average an
hour more than people in control conditions.
For example, people that got the same simulation
with someone else's face instead of your own.
Something real powerful about watching yourself
gain weight as a function of inaction and
then losing it when you get to --. Because
you're connecting the physical behavior with
what you all want to be.
So she's changed your behavior up to a day
later.
But that was self-report.
We don't always trust it.
So in a follow up study, she brought subjects
in, gave them this type of simulation, then
took the helmet off, paid the subject.
Said, "you know what?
Next guy's not coming in for 20 minutes.
You got some weights over there if you want
to work out you can."
People in this situation simulation worked
out for ten minutes longer on average than
control conditions.
So people stayed in the lab in their school
clothes working out voluntarily because this
idea of fitness had been driven home in such
a powerful manner.
We've replicated this a number of times including
eating.
So Jesse ran a study where subjects sat down
and were forced -- we took control of their
virtual arm and they were forced to either
eat Reese's pieces and watch their thighs
grow and their guts grow over or eat carrots
and watch it come off.
And we showed that change in eating behaviors.
A really nice idea there.
On the negative side Kathryn Segovia brought
in preschoolers to the lab.
And elementary school children.
Young children.
The first time anyone has ever taken my very
expensive virtual reality equipment and subjected
it to hundreds of children.
Very fascinating study.
And she wanted to ask about false memories.
So if a child sees herself swimming with a
whale does that become an actual memory of
something she thinks she does in a physical
world?
So in psychology a fairly large study on false
memory formations in the legal literature
and it's something that's very important to
understand if you're spending time in virtual
spaces, how is that changing your cognitive
structure?
And so children that came into the lab and
saw themselves swimming with whales compared
to subjects who saw another child swimming
with a whale, in the treatment condition of
the self, 50 percent of our children, a week
later when we brought them back, thought they
had been to Sea World, described the hot dog
they ate beforehand, the smell of the fish
tank, had encoded this as a physical memory.
One in two of our children believe they'd
done this physically.
Compared to controlled conditions, this is
much higher.
For children using or spending all this time
with digital media, it really raises some
concerns.
Grace Ahn ran a series of studies on what
she called sell self-endorsing.
This takes a big idea from science fiction
that if I'm wandering down the street and
a camera takes a picture of my face then you
encounter a billboard that has me using your
product and loving it.
How is that is that going to change my attitude
to the product.
In a line of four five studies that just got
published in the Journal of Advertising, you'll
like the product more.
You won't have a conscious memory of me being
in the billboard later on but you'll still
think the product is better for some reason.
So very powerful.
And then connection with a future self.
A line of studies we ran with Laura Carstensen
at the Center for Longevity at Stanford.
She's trying to have people have a good time
in their older age; to have a very enriching
life.
Children today aren't saving any money.
It's going to be a crisis hen when they do
the math about saving.
So when we brought subjects into the lab and
we aged them.
And so, 18 year old subjects went to the virtual
mirror, saw themselves as they're going to
look when they're 65 compared to seeing themselves
at their own age.
And the idea is that an 18yearold can't even
imagine what it's like to be a 30, let alone
65.
If I'm trying to get him to save money, let's
show him what he's going to look like when
he's 65.
And so, we did this and then the dependent
variable was we can give them some money now
or they can wait and get more money later
to put it in savings.
And what we're showing is that when you show
the future self compared to when you ask them
to imagine the future self, you get more savings
and very exciting results.
So I'm going to shift and conclude very quickly
because I want to leave time for Q and A,
about some work that I'm very excited about
because I think it's got some potential to
make the world a better place.
This asks about does it help if I can walk
in someone else's shoes?
And the first study was done with environmentalism.
So again, VR can can be thought of as a way
to help those very entrenched, hard to change
behaviors.
We all know we're not supposed to drive alone
to work.
We all know we're supposed to take shorter
showers.
And what we did here there's an op ed that
came out in the New York times that said if
you're using that beautiful, fluffy, non-recyclable
toilet paper, over the course of your life,
you're sawing down two virgin trees.
And so, what we did is half our subjects came
in.
All were told that statistic.
Half our subjects read a beautifully written
narrative about what it would be like to cut
down a tree.
The other half were forced to use this apparatus,
a haptic device, that simulated a chain saw
and literally cut down a tree.
And hear it thunderously crash around them
and the birds fly away.
And basically step into the shoes of a logger
and experience what it's like to do that.
And then what we did was Grace Ahn runs in,
she's visibly pregnant, 45 minutes later while
the subjects were leaving.
She knocks down a glass of water and says
"I'm pregnant.
Can you help me please clean this up?"
Subjects who got the virtual experience will
clean the mess using 20 percent less paper
than subjects who got the written experience.
So think about it.
Environmentalism , we all know we're supposed
to be green, but it's these hard to change
experiences that this disembodied virtual
avatar experience can change.
The next one deals with diversity training.
And we've done a lot of work with racism,
with ageism, with sexism.
The study I want to just briefly talk about
deals with attitudes toward the handicapped.
We made subjects color blind which is not
too traumatic of a handicap.
Half of our subjects imagined what it would
be like to not be able to differentiate between
red and green.
The other half we just robbed the ability
to see red and green by a filter on the virtual
world.
And so they had to go through some tasks where
it was very difficult to do the task because
you couldn't tell the colors.
Then later on we asked them to volunteer their
time surfing the web and writing down websites
that were hard for red- green color blind
people to see.
And people in the VR condition, compared to
the imagine you were color blind condition,
spent 20 minutes longer on average helping
color blind people compared to others.
Let me conclude.
Avatars can be more human than human.
That's actually a chapter in our book.
Really talking about how avatars can not make
me as good a teacher as I am physically but
a better teacher.
It's a really special cool ways that we can
make the world a better place.
And immersion is going to be a game changer.
If people are spending so much time online
right now and it's a flat 2D screen, what's
going to happen when, you know, we are we're
literally immersed in the content and we see
everything perceptually everything feels real
which is what we're moving toward.
And finally ethics are a great thing to talk
about.
All these things can be viewed as deception.
If I transforming my avatar, I am really hiding,
in some ways, who I am.
All of these things may not be worth doing.
It's a fantastic debate.
So I would love to get at least 13 minutes
of your questions and thank you for your attention.
[Applause]
>> Male presenter: That was a very good talk.
And my goal has always been to get to 6 feet.
But since I'm two inches short, my goal is
to make 60,000 dollars more now.
So if you have any questions, please come
up to the mic so that the folks on VC can
also hear it.
>> Female #1: So I have a question about several
of the experiments.
I can remember mirroring and face blending.
There are subjects are fairly unsophisticated
in the techniques that can be created in a
virtual world.
Do you get any sense that over time humans
will become more sophisticated about what's
happening in this world and what's being done
and will that make a difference to their reactions
in this space?
Because we seem to get more sophisticated
about other technology.
>>Jeremy: It's a great question.
So the question is subjects in my studies
may not have known anything about VR and as
we get used to the technology, none of this
is going to work.
I think there's a good truth to that which
is there is a novelty effect what we're going
to see is an arms race very similar to spam
and spam blockers.
People using these transformations, people
realizing they're not real, and then someone
having to go to the next level and going back
and forth.
One thing I like to say is my purpose is to
inoculate.
With the political morphing, I get approached
by political consultants sometimes.
I just don't do that work.
I view my goal as informing the public.
And when you consciously are aware of this
stuff, so when I tell you that candidate has
stolen your face, that backfires.
And so, this is truly a case of knowledge
is power.
And then the question is how sophisticated
are the users compared to the people trying
the transformations.
>> Male #3: So, could you give us an idea
what things avatars don't work for?
You must have had some negative results over
the years.
>> Jeremy: So, great question.
There's many things that don't work.
Those, academia doesn't reward you for publishing
things that don't work.
One thing we tried was whites and blacks.
We took white people and put them in black
avatars and forced them to walk a day in the
shoe of someone who's black with the idea
we wanted them to gain an empathy.
And that was the case where we didn't actually
reduce racism.
We actually increased it.
So there's a fairly large literature on racial
priming which is that some whites, when you
remind them of blacks, that changes their
behavior in a negative way just because it's
called priming.
Unfortunately American whites generally have
negative associations in general with blacks.
We thought if we put you in an avatar and
show you what it's like to be a different
race that would help and this is one instance
where it backfired on us and we're still doing
follow ups on that.
I can talk for hours about the studies that
haven't worked.
>> Male #4: The studies that rely on mainly
on looks like Veja Du and face morphing, I'm
wondering if you've even looked at identical
twins and if they're still susceptible to
the results.
>> Jeremy: It's a great question.
So the question was do they work on identical
twins in a different way.
I'd love to do that study.
It's hard finding enough identical twins.
There are scholars who do that for the people
who study evolution.
But I'll put that on the list.
That's a great idea.
>>Male #5: So you talked about the trade off
between real inches and real money.
Have you thought about virtual money versus
virtual inches and all those other possible
permutations of that.
>> Jeremy: The question is have we thought
about how this thing deal with virtual money
as opposed to to real money.
My colleague, Jim Blascovich, quote unquote
real money U.S. dollars are supposedly a stand
in for gold.
Currency by definition is representation of
something else.
But we have looked at specifically Linden
dollars in some of our studies and found similar
effects.
Great question, thanks.
>> Male #6: So you've done a number of different
studies.
Which was a result that so surprised you that
it was like "oh" but you were completely surprised.
>>Jeremy: Great question.
The question is which study surprised us the
most.
And there's a line of work I didn't get to
talk about in this talk that we call Digital
Footprints and this how many guys have seen
this New Yorker comic on the Internet "nobody
knows you're a dog" that shows a dog on the
Internet.
We've run a study actually the military is
actually sponsoring a huge program with lots
and lots of people studying this which is
based on what I call your digital footprint
which is the stuff you leave behind in a virtual
world.
So on a web you leave behind cookies.
In a virtual world you leave behind where
you walked, everything you've said.
So in this online world Second Life you can
record everything everybody does; who they're
standing next to, if they're flying or walking.
We've run studies now -- I ran a study where
I took 80 Stanford students.
They spent 10 hours a week in Second Life.
And they put on these buttons that recorded
everything they ever did in Second Life.
But I also knew who they were in the first
world.
They were my students.
I knew their gender, I knew their age, I knew
their GPA, I knew their major.
I knew they fill that personality metrics.
And then what we then did is we used machine
learning algorithms which are statistical
methods where you can correlate data with
a right and wrong answer.
And what we did is we said can I use this
digital footprint, this massive amount of
data we're collecting on a second/second basis.
Think about this: 80 student students,ten
hours a week, every second collecting about
50 parameters on what they're doing in the
virtual world.
Can you take all that data and find me some
pattern that I can detect a man from a woman.
Can how you walk in Second Life, does that
tell me your gender or your age.
And what we demonstrated with extremely high
accuracies much higher than I thought possible,
I can tell a lot about you, your personality,
your race, based on things we thought were
anonymous.
So the joke is yes you may think that on the
Internet nobody knows you're a dog but it
turns out we know you're a dog.
We know quite well.
The Internet and virtual worlds in particular
have this illusion of being anonymous.
Everything -- it's not me it's an avatar.
But it turns out the digital footprint you
leave behind in a virtual world, is more damning,
in many ways, or depending on the point of
view more wonderful, than any face to face
encounter could be because there's a record
of every single behavior done by every person.
Whereas face to face, I can do something embarrassing
but I can lobby later on for all of you not
to tell anybody; but in a virtual world that
doesn't work.
>> Male presenter: Other questions.
>>Jeremy: Thanks guys.
Thanks a lot.
Appreciate it.
[Applause]